monkey yeah today
what are we doing right now going to the
dentist and how do you feel about that
I don't know are you a little bit
nervous
no you know what you're so brave because
when I was your age I was so scared to
go to the dentist
and this is what your third time going
third time one time it was in California
another time was here and then another
time it's more back
oh and you like it every time
no well but to keep your teeth healthy
so you don't get any cavities you don't
have to pull any out and then they can
tell you if your new teeth are coming in
okay so we are at one of my favorite
dental places ever I've never liked the
dentists outside of Bart's Uncle who's a
dentist out in Taiwan he is so gentle
and the best and if I had him since I
was a kid I would not be as traumatized
as I am today but
um Summerlin Smiles if you are in Vegas
and you're looking for a really
um gentle comprehensive patient
um dentist Summerlin Smiles is this spot
but let me warn you they get booked so
fast this appointment was literally I
had to wait like almost six months
because it's just so booked which is
kind of perfect because I you know we
get our teeth cleaned every six months
so
um it gets really packed but yeah
not nervous actually but a little bit
nervous just because I have like
a guard from when I was
like I'm sorry I keep cussing but you
know better not to say those bad words
oh not Daniel's bad words no I did I was
a bad boy
girl I was a bad girl
okay you ready to go inside
um yeah
okay let's go inside and Anna that looks
like coyote your dog
[Applause]
you can't fall asleep dude
watching minions making yourself at home
you bozo look you're gonna have
raspberry flavored
um what is that for it's toothpaste
they're gonna use a machine that has
like a brush it's kind of like your
toothbrush
put your feet down
[Applause]
[Music]
are the monsters living in there nothing
I can see yet
[Applause]
she needs to see
open
big
thank you
it's cool huh
I can see a tiny bit of buildup and here
and there so let me go ahead and get
that oh all right did you put water in
my mouth no that was just air
the water in your mouth is saliva
because there's a water canal from the
mountain yeah that's your life
[Music]
okay yeah
yeah
[Applause]
it kind of hurts it's a little weird huh
so we are finished with the dentist
taika yeah how many cavities did you
have
zero how many cavities did I have
no at zero cavities woohoo so it was
just a quick little cleaning taika what
did it give you
show them show them
this other one
this one this one that was one thing I
loved about selling to the dentist was
getting the free stuff
even though I didn't use it because I
always had cavities
are you sure
show me
show me what you got
pull it out
[Applause]
you picked the Spiderman oh a blue one
wow these are fancy okay a toothpaste
this one tastes like
I don't know it's a Kids one
good job
am I crazy yeah okay okay take it easy
okay I love you
I feel like that's not what he was
initially gonna say but we'll just
accept it I love you too monkey
[Applause]
now we're at lunch and Tyga's getting me
water
look at how good he is the concentration
the focus
and he made it oh
thank you dude thank you so much one
super bad thing about Vegas is um since
there's a lot of like
yeah since there's a lot of bodybuilding
and stuff out here you have places like
Greens and Proteins that will tell you
all of the macros and it's super diet
friendly and it actually tastes really
good if I go no more okay why is there a
giant truck in my front yard because
we're laying the concrete today baby
oh
whoa
look at all that come from over there
so I always like the cement part of
construction because it feels like
getting a tattoo because it's so
permanent I mean obviously it's not
permanent I mean tattoos are from it
either you can get laser tattoo removal
but once you start laying the concrete
it's really hard to get rid of it you
gotta crack it get a jackhammer so
anytime I start seeing them lay concrete
I'm like oh shoot it's happening so
they're laying the concrete on this side
and the sooner they get this done the
sooner they put the patio up the sooner
we can have our outdoor gym which I am
extremely excited for because our gym
has been getting cramped in there we've
been getting more and more equipment so
we don't really have space to move
around once you have it back there we're
going to be able to train in the
outdoors and feel really really good
then we can start organizing the house
because you guys might be going man you
guys haven't organized a house one bit
looks like you guys still just moved in
and it's because we have so much stuff
in the garage that we need to move it
from the other garage to the other
garage so we can clear out all the other
boxes and inside the house so this is
kind of like one of the first dominoes
that lead to another a bunch of other
dominoes that's gonna clean up the house
these guys are pro
look how straight it is over there
already
[Applause]
okay Mama so I just got finished telling
them that concrete is my favorite part
of construction because to me it's
almost like tattoo it's like the most
permanent part of it you know you could
like draw things lay things out move
sand around but the minute you lay
concrete yes tattoos you can get laser
removal but it's like yeah but it's
pretty permanent and it feels permanent
because like you know when you when you
talk to your friends you're like is that
in concrete like are you really gonna
wash my car yet is that in concrete like
it's the same you know yeah yeah so
that's what I'm so excited to see it
concrete I've always heard it in stone
for sure on cement oh
we grew up in the same place I don't
know about you but look at that
look at that
that's cool huh
over here in the back Isn't that cool
yeah is that real yeah he has trust
issues because of me yes did he trust
you no what did I do
put um
what what are you doing over there are
you kidding me
it's down on the couch are you kidding
me
hey monkey man
you want me to tell you something cool
so we got to do this we got to do this
maybe right when you come home from
school or right when Papa comes home but
when the cement is still wet we can
carve our names in the cement and
they'll stay there forever you wanna do
that
you want to do that Mama write our names
in the corner somewhere
that's cute
without actually huh
what is it monkey you want to tell you
want to show me something there's a fish
they put it in now
oh wow that's a nice fridge
oh that's gonna go over there that
little hole right there
are you smelling it
crazy bones
so new update we're getting everything
ready for a major inspection because
once this stuff gets inspected we can
move forward with filling up the pool
which is why a lot of the big old tools
are cleaned up obviously still obviously
still a mess because the construction
site but we got all of this laid out now
they put stucco
on the bottom
still needs to get tiled but they unbox
the fridge so that'll go in here
this is done
oh
Mia come
here
they finished that pillar right there
ready for RV doors I know it could put
so much cool stuff through here
now we have to like get a dirt bike and
ATV and park it back here for sure so
yeah that's how we got the whole um
RV width gate so we can park stuff back
here if we need to and we widened this
whole path I think this path is like
seven or eight feet wide and it goes all
the way
like this so you see how it's like crazy
wide now and we widen our driveway which
is super cool because originally our
driveway only came up to
here if you guys remember like it was
like this line you see where that corner
is it came out right there because only
enough for one car but we played
basketball
um
yeah it's all plants so what we did we
almost not even doubled it but we almost
tripled it all the way that way yeah
this was like a plant like it was just a
waste of space yeah but now we got all
this
space
the play the only to run around
and then also the play CUNY
Mia bad girl
do that oh God
yeah we can play basketball here
so yeah this is our major update so far
and this view is killer off to the side
the side of the house oh my goodness
this is beautiful
um what is it called the scale of it
because yeah you would have to zoom into
that there's like a truck parked there
and it looks like a little little
Tic-Tac yeah like it's massive
but yeah it's beautiful just even
looking at that it'd be cool to even set
up some chairs here maybe like a
swinging chair
yeah our Gym's gonna be it's not gonna
be tight training in the mountain
backdrop like that
oh oh okay okay okay